- I hear they have a
nickname for you in Korea.
I love this nickname.
Did you love it?
- It was, it was...
- [Kelly] Is it The Nation's Boyfriend?
- Yeah.
I was like, do I say this myself?
- Nation's, I think, is it?
The Nation's Boyfriend.
- Yeah.
I was called The Nation's Boyfriend.
- That's just like everyone's boyfriend.
I'm just, look at, yeah, yeah.
The Nation's Boyfriend.
What does this mean?
Have you asked?
- I was told, so pretty much in Korea
there's a phrase called (speaking Korean).
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So that means one
Eric Nam per household.
So it's like...
(audience laughing)
It's like actually kind of
in like, the dictionaries
and if you search it, it's a thing.
- Oh, you're like Beyonce
with Bootylicious.
You just like made a word.
That's incredible.
- But here's the thing, I didn't make it,
I don't know who made it,
but it was made and then all of a sudden
I was on this this fun reality show.
It was reality where I'm fake
married for like nine months.
- Yeah.
- And through that
and through being on all these,
I know, I know, I know.
- How did you like being married?
How did you like being married?
- It was great.
- It doesn't stick for everyone.
- Well, mine was like nine months.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- You know, again.
- Some are.
Yeah, in reality.
- Also true.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But it was fun.
But it was through doing a lot of shows
and I was on any sort of TV
show, radio show, anything.
Everywhere.
And I think people just
really saw me everywhere,
and I think people liked me in general.
- Yeah, you're very likable.
- Thank you so much.
- Yes, you are very likable.